foreign
[Music]
company has to pay out four million
dollars to customers after being accused
of tracking people's use without their
knowledge
what why
yeah dude right what's the big deal
there's a Canadian brand called We Vibe
right they've agreed to basically have
to pay ten thousand dollars per customer
whoa okay after they've sold these
so-called smart vibrators uh which kind
of inadvertently tracked their use and
the whole point of it is because of a
certain type of tech it wasn't like
specifically for data collection I guess
so you would say it's probably one of
those things where you could control
your vibrator from the phone or some
[__] and it could track off and it'll
turn it on yeah the whole point is to
kind of have that ability to be like
intimate let's say let's say you're like
traveling right let's say you're like in
Europe or some [__] like that but you
want to have a kinky mom with your wife
she sticks the vibrator in and from your
phone you can control and I'm like
no you're the one with the phone Nick oh
I'm eating pasta it's up his ass
but in order to do that the tech would
have to have like tracking and data and
like location device services and other
things like that or I need to know where
you are
the company was receiving that data and
holding on to it in a way that were like
uh this many times per use this level
like Cindy comes in two minutes Sandra
comes in a 30 minutes yeah it's like
that kind of data Nick pre-coms for 30
minutes
I'm dribbling babe well there you go if
somebody has that data what is that what
are they gonna do with that what do they
do like we're talking about was it like
a GPS they're like they'd be cutting
them coming over here coming over there
coming over here have you guys been
following the tick tock story China
wants every piece of data apparently
available ever
stats
therefore the a class action lawsuit was
launched in Illinois against the sex toy
manufacturer's parent company Stanford
Innovation or standard Innovation and it
was agreed that the company would pay a
four million total with up to ten
thousand dollars for customers who use
the associated app as well as the
vibrator and 200 for those who had
simply bought the sex toy they must make
a lot of money man yeah can I ask how
the customers were aware of the class
action lawsuit yeah like hey you've been
using this dildo like you need to get a
mailer say Hey you hardcore using this
dildo right now probably because if you
if you signed up because they're like We
Vibe we connect app or whatever you
probably haven't put in something like
your email yeah they probably had to
take that that list
I'm making it too large do you think
when you open up the Wii Connect app
it's like
let's go it's probably like a Better
Call Saul commercial type thing yeah
oh yeah
billboard trying to think of that the
[__] the name of that retirement home
but Better Call Saul stand for sandpiper
though that's what it was I gotta watch
it yeah description of the item red
touch the screen to control the
vibrations and build intensity tease and
please with custom Vibes you create turn
on your lover when you connect and play
together from anywhere in the world
build excitement with secure in-app
voice chat and video make it vibrate
like [__] it in Saudi Arabian over here
and you can speak into it like oh and
then the [__] vibrator talks dude
yeah it's Kamala Harrison don't count
what the hell don't come don't When
someone tells me not to it makes me want
to even more 40 scene don't come oh [__]
wow she says it with her her fist too
all the way don't come like that that's
what it sounds like to me
because you want to break the rules oh
yeah of course not so it was revealed
it's VP dude it was revealed that the
app enabled
I guess so um it was revealed that the
app was collecting and sending data back
to standard Innovation including how
often it was used and on which intensity
giving a fairly robust record of the
user's intimate habits according to
court documents around 300 000 people
purchase bluetooth enabled Levi products
while around one-third of those also use
the app so I mean standard Innovation
stress that the information only be used
for Diagnostic purposes but I mean data
apparently data is a huge deal you know
what's the big thing like is the big
deal it's not the stats it's just the
fact that it has record of who is using
it that's all I see it they probably
didn't want to sign up for that they
didn't want their name being associated
with the fact that they use this thing
but who cares if it's just Anonymous
stats that's like those old school like
porno infomercials like if you buy from
us we'll use discrete labels discrete
packaging yeah and I thought your credit
card it doesn't say like [__] [__]
college girls whatever it says like the
blueberry Express or something
this sounds just it's so shady though
bro yeah blueberry Express sounds like a
stripper's name yeah or like Playboy's
used to arrive like wrapped in like
brown paper
or the black paper bag a black plastic
bag and you're like you know those are
playables why would they be wrapped
who's getting Playboys in the mail is
the question a lot of it back in the day
everybody wanted people didn't go to
like like stores and just go get that
[__] I had a I had a 70s Playboy that I
was cutting up for a collage and then um
the I looked at the you know the card
that for how much to pay if you want to
subscribe that [__] was 15 bucks for
three years whoa
70s 70s that's a lot recently on JK we
were talking about we were talking about
the WWF remember China yeah how she had
a huge quit and then the next day he
sends me a Playboy of that he found of
China oh yeah in his house yeah what is
a huge [__] his bathroom covered in jizz
Pages stick it again so glazy I bought a
box of like because I needed a bunch of
70s magazines and and I went to Long
Beach antique market and there was a guy
who had a box assistant 50 bucks yeah I
was like what's in the box he's like
just tons of
I opened it up and it was just it was
like penthouse uh Playboy like all those
like 70s so play girl in there but then
one of them was like from the 90s or
early 2000s had China on it what a 70s
Penthouse look like because I remember
furry the original Penthouse they're the
ones that are down to like spread the
lips like on the cover yeah that you
will see that but it's still mostly adds
all of these magazines are mostly ads or
or like uh columns it's like uh articles
any cool ads I remember cracking open a
fresh Playboy and just like wow
this is so cool it's like a video game
and then each page it's like they're
taking off an item of clothing and
you're like wow wow but it was still so
like PG-13 compared to like Hustler
magazines oh yeah oh yeah it almost says
cracking open though it hits different
Playboy and Penthouse they never showed
actual sex ever
Hustlers and stuff was the ones I had
didn't have no actual sex but the
positions chicks are like [__] open
their butt holes in the show it was like
red shoe Diaries photo prints it wasn't
really anything I remember in the
military some of our friends had some
crazy [__] it was like Euro smut or some
[__] like that it was like those are
some like liquor store bags though some
crazy I was like what the [__] chick
supposed to bowling pins and stuff like
that it was like crazy [__] yeah there's
some crazier things but these were like
gentlemen's magazines can you imagine
back in the day someone actually like
unfolded the centerfold like you're
reading the magazine and then you're
like
you're watching people open Playboy like
in what situation you're gonna be seeing
that when I had a Playboy I for sure was
looking at the [__] Centerville being
like oh [__] damn like her [__] cooch
is like right here
it smells new older Playboy yeah it
would be it would be a little bit more
hairy it'd be like covering yeah there's
lots of like hairy bush in those old
ones and the super old Playboys that is
very classy like I actually have one of
those playable magazines but the really
really old ones that had like the old
school drawings in cartoon yeah that's
just like it's almost like a table
decoration it's funny because a lot they
have that now a lot at thrift store I
mean like vintage shops yeah yeah
antique stores yeah they used to do
letters of the editor it was like some
guy just writing
titties and they have to answer them and
they're like thank you for your
thanks for your letter Eugene because
most of the ads are like cigarettes
which you never see cigarette ads
anymore oh wow um or they're like like
uh men's clothing or
um or it's it's speakers like sound
systems huge things
yeah home theater systems like every
other thing was like a home theater
system like there was a sound bar killed
remember like yeah remembering Boogie
Nights had the dude who's like a home
theater salesman thing that was huge in
the 70s that's right massive everybody
wanted home theater this is so weird big
upsells yeah do you remember how the
foreshadowing for that because like he's
selling the sound systems and at the end
the sound system is such a huge part of
that [__] scene yeah so good I love
it surround sound I'm so glad you were
in the ending to that movie what's that
I'm so glad you were in the ending to
that movie oh dude yeah I was the guy
was the [__] the stunt cuff in the 90s
midnight your monkey Mark's dick that
was my first job in L.A were you 17 yeah
everyone got arrested
[Music]